all right trey
what's good man
trey where'd you grow up where are you
from originally
originally i'm from
san bernardino california
but um
after my dad died we moved around a lot
to oakland uh washington
um
and
back down
and uh
just man all over all over the west
coast basically how old were you when
you lost your dad i was two years old
oof
how would you describe your childhood in
general
i would say it was the lack of childhood
basically man uh
i i inherit to pain
is the way i always look at it because
uh some of our first memories were
you know on the streets in shelters
and um
abuse
you know it was kind of like
being born in the middle of a war
you know because my mom she was at war
with her feelings and
you know having nine kids
and you know my my dad dying and leaving
it all in her hands was just one of
those situations to where
it was impossible for her to be mentally
stable
but it's not something you'll realize
you don't recognize as a kid you know
but uh
i mean clearly i wasn't uh you know a
normal kid
given you know
being born in the situation i was born
in because
i saw that you know my mom when she
what she did to us
was
just her dealing with her pain you know
what i mean
um
my first memories
was
i i guess it was like one of my clearest
first memories i was at the bottom of
the stairs
and my mom was coming down the stairs
and this is when we were in washington
we had moved to washington we uh came
down uh from oakland
uh in fresno
you know it was kind of like we we came
back we came down from uh from living in
in san bernardino we came down
oakland no family would help us out we
came fresno nobody would help us out
and
we made it down to washington which we
didn't even have any family at the time
and
which is crazy this is important
is that on the road to washington
it was in the middle of the night
i was about it was it was 91.
i was about three or four years old
and
my mom was driving
we were somewhere in the mountains in
the hills
and
i could hear my mom praying out loud
and um
she started crying and i looked around
and my siblings you know everybody would
sleep in the car
and i hear her praying out loud and she
said she said god
if there's a purpose for any any of
these kids in the car if there's a
future if there's anything
uh anything uh
uh great in this family if there's
anything that you have a purpose for
this and his family in this car right
now then you'll stop me
and i was thinking what does she mean
and
she started going faster
and she got full speed
and it was raining too it was raining
and
she kept on going faster and i got up
and i was looking around i was seeing
different some of my siblings are gonna
wake up nobody was waking up
and
all of a sudden she just shh
stopped super stopped super super fast
and super hard and we spun out on the
freeway
and
we had went so close to the edge
that we could have like if she didn't
stop it
sooner
we could have fell off
all of us would have died
and later my mom told me you're in a
hill huh you were in the hill
we were um we were in uh grant's pass
off the road
yeah she was gonna she was gonna kill
all of us
and she was she said she was talking to
god and she said that she told them
if she had a purpose then she would he
would stop she would stop the car
and what she had told me later about
that incident is that
she said she heard clearly in in her ear
stop
and she's and and she she stopped the
car
and
i mean just right off the bat i mean
i've been dodging death you know what i
mean
that's pretty much the story of my life
that's how close and edgy my life has
been
so um how'd you lose your dad
heart attack
and um so basically uh moving forward we
we got to go to washington
and
my mom
just she just lost it man
she started abusing us like like really
bad i'm talking about bro it was so bad
to where she was beating us every day
she was beating us with extension cords
sticks switches
she had this thing called beat me night
and she would take out the vacuum
cleaner cord and she would strip us
naked
and tell us to lay in front of her
and we're we're little kids you know
what i mean like
tell a kid to get naked
and lay in front of you willingly
and she whipped us i mean and she wasn't
just she wasn't doing any like
she wasn't having mercy at all bro like
she was just
i mean i still have well i still have
marks on my body you know what i mean
i still have one that that busted open
right here i'll never forget
and uh it was one of the the wire from
the court she had she used it so much
that the wire got exposed on the cord
and it just
it was bad man
but um
man everytime i think about that it's
crazy that's that's just like this just
a small part of it bro it got worse
it got to the point to where my mom
she
lost it so much to where she said that
she was going to read our minds
she said i'm going to read your mind
like and and if you're thinking anything
bad
then i'm gonna beat you so that double
dip from getting beat once a day
to like coming home from school and
she's a she's on the other side of the
door behind the door hiding
a lot of times like we would just we
were coming the door and run and duck
because we knew that she was behind
there and she would just start beating
us
for no reason
you know what i mean so it got to the
point to where home just felt
like a cult you know what i mean it felt
it felt
it felt like
you're always in danger you know i mean
no matter how much you told her you
loved her or no matter how much
uh you know no matter how how good a day
was the day was going to end with you
getting beat you know what i mean
it got so crazy bro to where
so all of us resemble our dad
you know what i mean all the all the
boys we resembled our dad
it got to the point to where when we
smiled and laughed because we when we
smile most of the time we smile on the
side and that's a trait that comes from
my dad
what she would do she would take our
face twist it and smack us really hard
so imagine how many times that happened
today
so if she caught us smiling or laughing
that's what she did
so
man it just got really really bad it got
so bad to where
my
my older brothers uh my other brothers
uh i don't want to say their names on
here if you don't mind
um but um
they the the two of the older ones they
they ran away
and
when they ran away it got the pressure
got more on whoever was left
so
man
it was a
a night that i'll never remember i mean
a night that i'll never forget sorry
and that i'll never forget was when my
mom
beat me and my brother
for like two hours straight
she beat us so bad
to where she didn't send us to school
for a month because she thought child
protective services was gonna get called
and i remember because
after i got beat
i went into the bathroom
and
my brother uh
my closest brother
he was getting beat and i remember
me and him were really close especially
after the older ones left and i remember
the sound of the sound of his scream
like when she was beating him and for
how long it went on for
i remember like
just crying just bawling my eyes out
like man it was it was
it was horrific man it was it was kind
of like hearing somebody getting
tortured
ever since then like
even as we got older i always hated the
sound of hearing my brother cry
you know what i mean it was always one
of those triggers for me
that
i didn't i didn't want to experience him
i never wanted to hear him cry like i
always wanted to try to make our lives
better
after getting out of there
how we got out of there was a miracle
though
so
after that after the the
crazy night
about two months later
she woke me and him up in the middle of
the night
and she did it again
and this time it was it was really about
nothing like really about nothing she
said that she read our minds
and that she felt that we were thinking
we were thinking bad thoughts about her
were drugs a part of your mom's life
we never knew and i want to i want to
say that she probably was what if i was
older and
i'm sure if i looked into it
that it probably was man
it probably was you know
you know
the neighborhoods that we lived in i
mean
yeah you know when we moved to
washington we lived on hilltop i don't
know if you ever heard of hilltop
washington in tacoma it's come to
washington it's a big pretty crazy area
especially around the time we were in
the 90s there were people dylan dope
right on the street corner you know
and it was you know it was just a
regular thing so there's a chance that
she probably was you know it was really
nothing you could do about that
environment you know
so
that night
she she pulled us out and she had this
futon
and she she told us both to get naked
so we stripped down naked she brought
out this cord
what she did with this cord man is she
braided it
she braided an uh an extension cord to
another extension cord
to the vacuum cleaner cord so it's like
a three prong cord about that thick
and she exposed the wires on it this
time and she twisted them so it was kind
of like what did they call a catalytic
uh whip
and
just
have had us both lay down in front of me
and she just
beat us
just beat us and we got up and ran she
got us in the corner and just beat us so
those welts everything on our face and
just
so
after after that happened
my brother pulled me aside
and um
and he was like man he said
we got to get out of here
we said we got to get out of here or i
feel like she's going to kill us
we're going to you know she's probably
going to just go too crazy one day
you know
we're probably not going to live
especially after that night i felt like
i felt like i was dying it got to the
point i don't know if anybody watching
this if you felt the point to where
you're in so much pain to where like
your body kind of gives you a morphine
to where like
it's
you're kind of numb but at the same time
it still hurts
kind of hard to explain but
i felt like she was coming up with
creative ways of of beating us you know
and he was right you know i felt i feel
like if we if we did stay that she
probably would have eventually killed us
you know
so uh my brother was like this is what
we're gonna do he said
he said we're gonna um we're gonna when
we take the trash out
we're gonna uh put our backpacks inside
of the garbage and then what we're gonna
do is when we get the garbage can we're
gonna take our backpacks out place up on
the side
of the can and then when she actually
just to bring you back in
we're going to run for it
and so i remember it was it was a
hilltop tacoma it was
may 21st 1997.
i was
11 years old
11 or 12. i think i was either 11 or 12.
or i was 11 going on 12. i was going
down twelve that january i would have
been twelve i i believe so
and uh he was thirteen
and um
man
i remember like was yesterday i closed
my eyes
there's a lot of life-defying moments
you know what i mean like
i feel i feel like um
i don't know i think about my brother
when he was young
i feel like
i think about my uh
i think about my uh
my brother when he was young
and um
i remember
being uh so full of life you know what i
mean like um
we had a lot of life plans you know what
i mean like
he was like you know we're going to get
out of here and we're going to um
and you know somehow someway we're just
going to be better
you know
um we're not going to uh
we're not going to end up like people
think we're going to end up
because i mean if you think about it
what's the statistic right you know
when you're
when you're um
when you're raised in a certain
environment right like
you're raised in a certain environment
people people tend to think that like
you're either gonna uh you you know
you're gonna end up on drugs or you're
gonna die or you're gonna end up in
prison
so we always reach for something higher
you know what i mean so
young
the younger brother you know what i mean
like when i think back you know i think
back to him uh thinking about how full
of life he was and
you know how optimistic it was you know
it's just man
i smile and it
it makes me happy to think of him that
way to think about you know
what eventually happened
but
that day
we went out to the garbage cans
we grabbed our backpacks
and we we ran
we ran for
i feel like it was like for a mile
two miles
when i when i look back at it i'm like
that was like
the run to freedom you know what i mean
like
and i just wish that it was it was us
headed into a better situation
you know what i mean
i feel i feel like
god's got a plan and but as long as you
follow it through you know what i mean
but
life is life man
when we ran away
we um
we eventually uh
ran into our older brother
you know
and at the time um
at that time in that in the in the 90s
hilltop was
a beast man
it was it was swallow your whole it was
kind of like
like you know l.a in a lot of ways a lot
of people called it to compton
tacoma they called it the compton and
they they called it that for a reason
because it was pretty crazy man
now me being my age
i was very imp impersonable you know
what i mean like so
a lot of people you know left a lot of
impressions on me
and um
my brother
you know he he hit him and uh you know
and my other older brother
they they lived in a trap house
so there was a lot of dope dealing going
on
there was a lot of shootings in the uh
that happened in that area
and that on that block radius
i mean
the chances of survival were just like
slim really slim bro
i almost died like within the first
few months of being there
now my brother worked on cars
and
uh a lot of people from the hood you
know hilltop hilltop gangster [ __ ]
you know what i mean like hey for people
from acg people from hoover people from
all
gangs all over that in that area would
come to and get their car done they
would get their sounds hooked up you
know and i would go out there and i
would you know be washing the white
walls i would take the white rock you
know what i mean with the bleach
and i and i would uh you know do the
white walls so you know i mean like it
was a spot to come through barbecues all
sorts of things going on and people's
park was right across the street
so um
one day
uh this dude comes through and he had
you know he had impala
and um and he was he had a lot of he had
a gang of sounds in the back man he had
this pexi glass that covered the whole
trunk
and he had uh 12
215's and my brother was doing redoing
the sounds for him and hooking up a
screen all that like he was
hooking up his system
but my brother took off right my brother
had to go do something
and
the girl that he was married to
she had a cousin
like i said i'm not going to say any
names
and that cousin was he was known to do
some sketchy stuff you know and so my
brother told me he was like hey you know
just just keep an eye on it for me you
know watching while i'm gone i was like
oh for sure you know he said you know
clean the white walls and all that he'll
give you like 10 bucks you know and i
was like cool
so
um
so out of nowhere this dude comes
and
you know like at the time i was like i
was only like 11 12 years old
and
he
went to the car went through the whole
car was taking stuff out of it ripped
the deck out
took the sounds out of the back and what
he does with all the stuff
is he puts it all he hides it all in the
attic
and so
he knows i'm the little brother right
so imagine
there's only one witness
and i know who did it
when my brother comes back who thinks
the little dude's gonna tell you know
and who do you think he's gonna tell on
so that's what he was thinking
so
automatically he was like
pull me to the side
uh you didn't see nothing right
i'm i'm like hey look man like
i'll just tell him that i was in the
bathroom you know what i mean like you
know i i hadn't seen nothing
and about five minutes later he comes
back around
and i could tell that he was high this
time
you know what i mean like he was like
you're not going to say nothing right
you're not going to say nothing
and i was like nah i'm good man i'm you
know i haven't seen nothing man you know
i'm straight
and his girl comes his girl
is like even crazier you know
but she comes
she pulls them to the side and i see
them talking he pulls out his gun
and he looks over at me and she she's
whispering in his
ear he was like you know i think you're
going to tell i think you're going to
tell on me
if you're telling me you know
they have to just get rid of you
and the girl she pulls out her gun and
was like let's just let's just do it
right now
this is killing
and i'm sitting here thinking like man
the sounds are probably only worth like
500 something like that on the streets
i'm going to get killed over like 500
dollars
so
well they did
at gunpoint they grabbed me
they wrapped me up socked me in the
stomach had me down on the ground beat
me up
and
what the what they uh her idea was she
was like we should take him down to the
basement
let's kill him
take him down the basement we'll stash
his body somewhere you know
i was small enough they could just
put my body in like a box or something
like that until i guess i started
smelling or whatever
but
they took me down to the basement
they had me down on my
knees this is no joke man
110 percent
hear the gun click
pull the hammer
back and i'm on my knees like
just kind of numb you know what i mean
like
yeah i've been through it all why
wouldn't it in this way
you know
not like i had a bright future or
anything you know
that was all discouraged anyway
and i i promise you
no joke the only reason why i'm sitting
right here
is
must have been an angel and i called
them angels even to this day every time
i talk to them online
is
my brother's
stepdaughters
busted open the door
no joke busted open the side door right
where i was on my knees at
and they grabbed me and run they were
like let's go let's run
i i don't even know how they knew that i
was getting ready to get killed
they weren't anywhere near the house
they had no idea what was going on it
was just me and him and his girl in that
situation
i promised you to this day and i still i
asked them they they don't even know all
they knew was to go through the side
door and to get to uh to go through the
house
he busted open the door they saw me on
my knees and they saw him with the gun
cocked back to the back of my head and
split second they grabbed me and ran man
i promise you no joke that's the only
reason why i'm still sitting here right
now
i would have died at a
stupid young age bro
but that was just that was just one of
the things man one of the things i feel
like i feel like i've been dodging death
constantly every time i turn around
you know what i mean
so a little bit after that you know that
that whole thing blew over and
you know
caesar left i mean my brother my brother
left and uh he got adopted by by another
family
so
um
they didn't they didn't want me because
they you know they said you know he's
crazy man you know
we can't control him you know he's he's
a loose cannon and which i was you know
i you know i
i
got to the point to where i had a
problem with
with authority you know what i mean
i had a record like this thick
uh being kicked out of schools and
always getting into fights
you know i figured
if my own mom didn't love me enough to
you know to to to
to have a normal life and have a
childhood you know
i didn't want to hear what anybody else
had to say you know
i didn't want to i didn't want to
hear anybody else's rules or try to
abide by anybody else's
you know standards or anything
yeah she's the kind of person i was
but
that that whole thing caught up to me at
school though
one time
i uh
i was just in ninth grade
i was in ninth grade
and um
by that time
you know i i i
gone up you know i've gone through
you know the whole orientation of the
streets you know what i mean
i was even banging the banging you know
uh and and slanging doing all sorts of
you know
crazy stuff at the time and
you know i was i was that much more
crazy you know i mean 10 times crazy i
was about
15 years old
about 14 15 years old
and uh you know i started freestyling
you know what i mean i'm over you know
uh
in the in the hip-hop you know
you know influence and
you know my brother my brother uh
older brother was doing it my second
older brother was doing it and
you know i took off with it
so i always found myself in the
freestyle sessions you know what i mean
and uh
this dude man
big dude real big dude man this dude was
uh
he was a
basketball player or something like that
either way dude was like he was
he was uh what ninth grade but he was he
was
pretty big man this dude was like six
five
six five not great you know he's a
pretty big dude so you know a lot of
people you know a lot of people you know
wouldn't wouldn't get in this dude's way
or anything like that so he hopped in
the session and you know he
thought he'd intimidate me right but you
know you don't know my life man you know
what i mean i i already been through it
so you know you never judge a book by
his cover after that i'm pretty sure he
he figured that out
but uh
so
he starts he starts you know
getting personal when that now and
you're in a freestyle session man
if you ain't rapping and you're just
talking without rhyming that you're just
talking [ __ ] you know what i mean and so
brothers started talking that you know
what i mean and i was like okay
you don't sound like you're rapping
anymore man
and so you're like no i ain't rapping no
more and boom push me i'm not like all
right
push big in bet you know what i mean he
pushed me again boom and so he pushed me
again i hopped up in midair and just
dropped him his whole his his jaw broke
in like 10 places
broke his jaw in 10 places he had to get
a uh he had to get
get it wired up from both sides
and uh he had to re he had to repeat 9th
grade again because of me
but i got arrested um i got arrested on
campus
i got expelled from school
and i was facing
um
what they say was
you know when you're doing when you're
when you're younger they they say it in
weeks they don't say it in years so they
were like uh like 38 weeks or something
like that 40 weeks of uh of um of
juvenile you know juvenile uh juvenile
like so i was going to be in jail for
like
a couple years you know i mean pretty
much i i blew high school you know what
i mean like
so
uh
so i was locked up for about two months
and uh
i was in court
you know uh would do they pressed
charges on me the parents pressed
charges
and so
um
i had to go to court
and uh i had no i had no
nobody uh speaking for me i had no no
witnesses that spoke for me
everybody that came in they they
testified against me
which is crazy man i'll tell you that's
how crazy i was like you know i mean
like as far as like being known
i was just known as that that crazy dude
that you don't mess with you know what i
mean i didn't really i didn't really
have friends you know what i mean i my
circle
wasn't a circle i didn't i i didn't
i didn't kick it with anybody after
school none of that you know
so
um
they pretty much i thought they pretty
much had me you know what i mean like as
far as i was concerned i was gonna i was
gonna be
in jail until i turned 18 and uh in
juvenile until i turned 18 and then i'll
go to jail and sort of rest of my
sentence you know
um
so
uh it was a day of the verdict
and uh the only person that that showed
up was my older brother
and um
it said the j instead of the judge you
know just you know passive verdict which
was everybody was like obviously he's
gonna go you know because like i said
nobody nobody testified on my behalf
and uh the judge the judge got up out of
his chair and he went and he grabbed
like this book and you know he he opened
it up and he was
and he was quiet it was real quiet it
was an awkward moment in court you know
i mean you don't you ever see this in
court and i've never seen it you know
what i mean
and he was like
according to a court case in 1929 you
know this is self-defense the guy pushed
him first
you know
uh what the the the what was afflicted
on the on him the broken drama that was
just self-defense
and but he he wanted to hear me rap he
asked me to come up he was like i want
to know what you were doing let me hear
you rap i promise you i promise you
i wrapped in court in court i wrapped in
court bro and it was dope too man i just
freaked out i freestyle basically
telling
talking to the dude that i beat up and i
was like uh i ended it like uh things
happened to stupid people my tickets you
learned your lesson
the judge was all like shaking his head
and everybody in the court was like oh
damn that was dope that was dope
and
acquitted me
acquitted me man acquitted me
it was like you know with self-defense
family gavin that was it
and i was like damn man like i did not
see that coming man i did not see that
coming
but i counted my blessings on that one i
kind of my blessings on that one bro
like i knew
at that point i was like guys looking
out for me you know what i mean like if
nobody else is looking down for me and
as crazy as my life is and as much as
nobody understands you know what i mean
or takes the time to understand because
to be honest with you they didn't you
know what i mean why should they you
know what i mean i'm just a young
another young black man you know what i
mean with the crazy attitude that's
pretty much what i looked like
but
it was dope to see
how that worked you know what i mean
then
because the truth was man
as much pain as i have on the outside
on the inside
i've always been looking for a home you
know what i mean i've always been
looking for a stable peace of mind but
sometimes that's not your life you know
you know i was 15 years old when i had
my first apartment
yeah man
i was living on the streets when i was
in high school
until i i i saved up
um i was i was i knew i was a uh
selling newspapers on a crew
and like i said like you know i keep to
myself so nobody knows you know i mean
teachers didn't even know that i was uh
writing my own letters man i was writing
my own letters and you know
sometimes i was staying at the bus
terminal across the street you know
sleeping and sleeping at the bus
terminal across the street until i could
get a get an apartment i saved up all
that money
got my apartment
and
stressed about rent man stressed about
renting a lot
sometimes i didn't show up to school you
know what i mean sometimes they show up
to class
but when i did you know what i mean
people people couldn't under you know
people didn't understand me
the only outlet that i had
was was
rapping you know i mean that's the only
time i felt good you know what i mean
and i just had i had a short temper
short fuse you know i mean i was always
ending up in the situation to where i
was getting arrested
always uh always in a fight and some for
some reason every time i was throwing
down there was a cop somewhere you know
what i mean
but
uh
that's what i was very good to
um
something
that i'll probably have in common with a
lot of people that come and talk on uh
on this channel is that
no matter
how much you try to put your mind to a
good place
sometimes the pain of the past is too
much
so
the whole trying to be normal thing just
doesn't work you know what i mean and
i'm not making excuses i'm just stating
facts
it doesn't work
so well
for us to normalize because
it's it's hard to deal with it
i'm not gonna lie man i i i
i didn't do i didn't do drugs
or drink alcohol until i turned 18 19
years old
you know
i guess until then it didn't it didn't
uh it didn't it didn't help
uh
only music was like music was like the
thing you know
i was i was
sic i was 16 years old when i dropped my
first album
and where i'm at today is
when i started that path
it was
between music
and keeping my mind
off of the past
and just trying to be happy you know
what i mean and and between those two
things
it's just going to look bad to everybody
else you know what i mean it's going to
look like hey man you know this guy is a
you know a drug user or you know
or uh you know just no respect for
authority or
you know
does it you know keeps himself too much
or you know
to be honest with you bro like
if i if i didn't have those two things
if i if i didn't you know drink i feel
like if i didn't drink and if i didn't
do drugs or if i if i didn't have
especially if i didn't have music man i
would probably blow my brains out bro
i'll probably blow my brains out and
uh i mean especially um since
about 10 years ago
the brother that i ran away with
uh
i only want to start crying again man
but
my brother my brother
wasn't that good with holding the pain
of the past back you know what i mean
he he was uh
he was a little bit more weaker weaker
at it than me you know what i mean and
because of that because he didn't have
music you know what i mean he didn't
have music he didn't have uh he didn't
have any extra you know
any extra things to to to hold them
together
so
he started doing he started doing drugs
when he was about 23 years old
and it took four years for it to kill
him
i found his body
at him in a motel room
i had a show the next day
and um
he wanted to he wanted to be alone he
said i just want to be alone man just
you know driving off the motel because
we're going to we're going to go to move
to sacramento me and him
you know um
and uh he was like man you know i just
want to be alone tonight just want to
you know i want to you know just to sit
sit alone and think and
he kept on hugging me man you know he
kept on hugging me he hugged me like
three times and i i shoulda i should
have known i feel like i should have
known you know
you know we were just going through a
lot
that that that last couple of years me
and never going through a lot you know
we were we were you know
going from place to place i mean me and
him were sleeping in the car or you
shouldn't be too and and
you know i was starting a music thing
and you know we were looking at that as
as a way to blow up and just you know to
finally be free and finally you know
finally lived that life that we wanted
you know i mean and put the past behind
us
but
he hugged me and he told me he was like
man don't ever quit doing your music bro
don't ever quit doing your music he said
you said
he said you're on the level you see
you're on the level bro he said yo you
said you're up there with the wheezies
and all those dudes he said trust me man
he said he said you're in a category on
your own
and so don't ever do stop doing your
music
and
the next day i came to pick him up for
the show
we came about an hour late
and
the door was locked
and the window was open
and he he he wasn't the only way you
know at your motel room the only way
that the door is going to be locked
you know if you especially if you could
see you know i mean you can see that
there's somebody in there you hear stuff
going on inside
i was like well he's definitely in there
because you know like his phone's right
there
i don't hear any snoring though my
brother's a loud snorer you know what i
mean
and i was like
my homeboy you know my guitars he was
like man you know he maybe he's just uh
you know maybe maybe he's just praying
or something like that maybe you know
maybe maybe he's got the headphones on
or something and i was like nah
and
so both of us like yelled at the top of
our lungs you know hey hey what's up man
you know let's go let's go
and i'm and
all of a sudden i had this bad feeling
man i i don't know i don't know what it
was that came over me but this bad
feeling
like this cold chill down my spine bro
like
that that he was gone
and um the motel manager came
and they they jimmy opened the door
and um
he was face down on the bed
and um
they said he had been dead since
the morning
and um
i went i went crazy i was
throwing paramedics
one of the cops i pushed one of the cops
over the bed and
[Music]
i'm on the corners and
i just
was trying to resuscitate him you know
what i mean i was pounding on his chest
tell him to come back
and the world seems like a
more lonely place you know what i mean
like it's just
i don't know bro like
that was like my only family you know
what i mean
i swear bro like everybody else is just
fake dude
all the people that tried to say they
care and
you know what i mean like
bro like
it's a crazy life it's a crazy life and
like it's so easy to tell when your life
is crazy it's so easy to tell who's
really got your back because there's so
many moments that if they don't really
got your back they ain't gonna be there
you know what i mean
trust me you know i mean somebody that
really don't want to be there is not
going to be there because
you know
i just i always tell myself what if i
was there early to pick them up earlier
and then another part of me says you
know what like
think about what he said the day before
you know what i mean
like
i honestly my brother was tired
i'm tired too dude like
in the last 10 years i've
i've thought about overdoing it
you know what i mean
because there's got to be something
better bro
you know i was talking to this a r
it's an art from sony records she got a
hold of me she wanted to
hear more of my story because she was
intrigued by the music
and at the time i walked
i walked across the country
i walked from los angeles to new york
just trying to get the paint out you
know what i mean
kind of like forest gump
got to put the past behind you you know
for some reason for some reason the pain
is always in front of me and it's behind
me and it's on the side of me
and she said i've never heard of
anybody's life being so chaotic she said
don't you have any family that would
help you out you know and try to help
you come up with your music because
you're worth it
i was like well thanks for telling me
that but
the truth is it's not there you know
what i mean
you know my dad died when i was two so
that was already like the failure you
know i mean of having the father figure
that would have been the ultimate health
they said my dad was a great man i'm
pretty sure he was
um
you know and i try to imagine my life on
on how it would be without all the
circumstances but the truth is
maybe i'm a cautionary tale you know i
mean what if god's just like hey you
know what
your music is going to be a cautionary
tale maybe it's going to be um
uh uh
a thing that somebody's gonna hear and
it's gonna lift them up you know what i
mean and help them get to their
situation you know what i mean
so
in some way
at all the crazy things that i've been
through in my life
that it's still helpful you know what i
mean it helps somebody
now when i look at it like that
then
i i i indulge it you know what i mean i
i i accept it and i indulge in it and
i'm saying hey you know
it's a testimony you know what i mean
and i'm just glad
that
maybe maybe somebody's gonna see this
you know what i mean and say hey you
know
you know that's inspiring maybe maybe
that'll
that'll help me
and if there is somebody listening you
know
just try to take the pain one day at a
time you know what i mean
all right trey
thank you so much for sharing your story
for sure
it's heavy
i appreciate you meg
god bless
you